non aujourd'hui je n'y suis pas
favorable je suis n'engage que moi en le
disant pour une raison très simple c'est
que nous n'avons pas assez de recul
scientifique et les spécialistes le
disent d'ailleurs sur des publics âgé
depuis 12 ans nous avons un vrai recul
parce qu'on a dans le monde d'accéder
massivement et donc on a forcément des
tests grandeur nature pour dire les
choses simplement sur les enfants ce
n'est pas le cas les seuls qui le font
massivement aujourd'hui sont les
américains on aura un recul dans
quelques mois et je pense qu'il faut
attendre d'avoir ce recul là vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui la vaccination peut avoir
des effets secondaires qui sont
marginaux sur le public adulte mais on
sait scientifiquement que plus le public
est jeune plus les effets secondaires
sont importants notamment sur le coeur
et je pense qu'il faut avoir cette
réserve la cette prudence là c'est
pourquoi je ne suis pas favorable à la
généralisation de la vaccination était
de sainte énimie mais aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas le cas et donc il n'est pas
question tant que la haute autorité
santé n'a pas donné son feu vert que
nous le fassions et je souhaiterais au
delà d'avoir le feu vert de la haute
autorité santé que nous attendions
d'avoir le recul nécessaire sur les
vaccinations en population générale qui
se font d'ailleurs je pense que la
prudence c'est aussi une exigence de
santé publique et voilà la raison pour
laquelle j'y suis défavorable
j'ajoute à cela que on ne peut pas
lancer de grandes campagnes de santé
publique avec une défiance qui pelade et
nous avons sur la vaccination des
enfants une défiance qui plane et donc
je pense que ce serait une mauvaise idée
du coup on attend combien de temps on
attend d'avoir le recul nécessaire ça
peut durer plusieurs mois si c'est
encore plus long et bien nous ne le
ferons pas c'est la proposition que je
formule aujourd'hui d'autant que le vrai
sujet c'est d'aller au maximum de la
vaccination sur les plus de 12 ans avant
de s'intéresser aux moins de 12 ans
interrompt son nom déjà à ceux qui ne
sont pas encore vaccinés parce qu'ils
n'ont pas confiance et que l'on doit
écouter et entendre et qu'ils ont plus
de 12 ans
[Musique]